es un cambio de enfoque que era
necesario urgente porque esa vieja
cúpula era está investigada por temas de
violaciones a los derechos humanos
perfilamiento a periodistas líderes de
la oposición y defensores de los
derechos humanos y tenían serios
cuestionamientos en materia de
corrupción lo que se hizo fue nombrar a
los generales que estaban en lo que se
conoce en términos militares reclutan
los de más abajo de la pirámide para así
poder quitar los que estaban encima e
intentar comenzar una nueva generación
en el generalato de colombia bien store
y estos cambios que ahora buscan poner
la atención alta en los derechos humanos
y que incluyen el nombramiento por
ejemplo de una mujer en los altos rangos
de la policía qué mensaje envían y
además qué efecto generan dentro de las
fuerzas
tres cosas primero las fuerzas militares
y sobre todos los retirados están muy
molestos con este gobierno por estos
cambios y por qué van a afectar cosas
como lo que ellos manejan doctrina
militar que ha sido una doctrina militar
muy de derecha muy propia de la guerra
fría donde siempre han visto a la
izquierda como el enemigo y les incomoda
mucho de estos cambios lo segundo que
llegue una mujer en la policía va a ser
vital porque el año pasado tuvimos
violaciones a los derechos humanos que
fueron documentadas por la comisión
interamericana derechos humanos que hizo
unas recomendaciones y que no se
cumplieron y se espera que la llegada de
una mujer otro enfoque y otros generales
puede hacer que haya una transformación
pero lo tercero es que tiene que dar un
cambio de doctrina en el en el tema
militar y policial de colombia razón por
la cual lo segundo que se va a hacer es
sacar a la policía del ministerio de
defensa y crear un ministerio de la paz
la seguridad y la convivencia ministerio
propio donde va estar la policía y lo
segundo lentamente en la formación de
las fuerzas militares el que se
construya una doctrina donde haya un
respeto por los derechos humanos bueno
sobre eso iba mi siguiente pregunta
porque ya lo dijo ustedes bajo este
gobierno policía es una de las
instituciones que más cambios verá con
la salida de 23 antiguos generales y
además este paso de cambio de cartera
qué implicaciones se tendría esa
modificación en su opinión en la manera
de operar de la policía
una policía más civil menos militarizada
y una policía que se empiece a acercar
más a los ciudadanos el problema de la
policía fue que termino del contexto del
conflicto armado y terminó en una
policía que parecía un ejército más con
capacidades militares helicópteros y
haciendo operaciones en la mitad de la
selva se necesita una policía más humana
y que tenga mayores estándares
internacionales y que pueda cumplir los
derechos humanos